everyone this is the daily Deni let's
get right into the breaking news
everybody is talking about it appears
Demi Lovato was reportedly rushed to the
hospital today after suffering a
suspected drug overdose here's
everything we know so far
TMZ reports the 25 year old singer
overdosed on heroin and was transported
from a home in the Hollywood Hills just
before noon on Tuesday and is currently
being treated according to an ET source
Demi is stable Demi has openly fought
substance abuse for years and a source
tells ety quote she has a lot of demons
she's been an addict more than sober for
most of her adult life
last month Demi confessed she had fallen
off the wagon after being clean for six
years the singer opened up about
relapsing in her new song sober everyone
goes through ups and downs and I'm
getting to write about that and I'm
sorry for the fans I lost who watch me
fall again I wanna be a role model but
I've been able to share my story with
other people and I've had fans that come
up to me and tell me you know because
you got sober I got sober
apparently in late May Demi had a
falling out with her sober coach our
source adds she's depressed has anxiety
and is always late she pushed people
away another source says her friends
have been worried about her lately and
adds she has been on a downward spiral
sometimes also struggle with past
behaviors kind of and cravings creeping
in celebrities have been flocking to
social media to send their support to
Demi including ariana grande Ellen
DeGeneres and Meghan Trainor the story
is of course still developing and we'll
keep you guys posted on the latest on
our site ET online.com let's move on to
some lighter news for now Mila Kunis is
now happily married with two kids with
Ashton Kutcher but back in the day eight
years to be exact
she dated Macaulay Culkin
yes they were a thing in Neela's 20s it
didn't work out and Melies finally
reveal ey to her pal Dax Shepard on his
podcast armchair expert no I stop like
that something that took me a long time
to come out and be like yeah you know
what I was a dick and I accepted and I
own it now
somila is taking the blame for the
break-up that went down in 2011 but
never actually revealed what she did
thankfully she had no problem in meeting
how she first hooked up with her now
hubby Ashton Kutcher and like most fairy
tales all it took was a little liquid
courage I had a little bit of tequila
okay I was it was the Golden Globes
uh-huh and I was standing backstage in
this very tall very good-looking stature
of a man walk by but then he turns
around and I was like look like it was
so like what like I caught myself be
like why am i checking out Mila revealed
Ashton actually tried to set her up with
one of his friends that isn't to his
buddy did he show up and well the person
got delayed at a wedding didn't show up
I didn't know this was happening that
was the night that he and I hung out
this week and then you get a little
tipsy no it's totally sober oh wow the
very first kiss when you're what are you
like I'll tell you this I while I was
single never spent the night at any guys
house yes this was the only time that I
ever spent the night at somebody is that
anyone else want to know what the
morning was like did he bring you
breakfast in bed
did you guys take a stroll through
Central Park and last night's outfit
Mila I need to know more Mila also
admits she and Ashlyn were crazy
neurotic keeping the relationship a
secret in the beginning and someone who
knows about a low-key relationship is
miss karlie class the model is engaged
to boyfriend of six years Joshua Kushner
and she come from the news on her
Instagram and while plenty of celebrity
and designer friends showered the couple
would love via social media we're still
waiting to hear from her pal Taylor
Swift so what's the deal are you two
okay my eyes are peeled Swifties now
someone who did congratulate Carly is
Haley Baldwin who recently got engaged
herself to Justin Bieber it's been 17
days since beef
to Haley and according to an ET source
justin has never been so happy and he's
never felt more sure about a woman in
his life so what is it about Baldwin
that's got Bieber so strung
we're told Justin his head over heels in
love with Haley they attend the same
church in our source says they're on the
same page about their faith our source
adds the two can't wait to get married
and maybe we won't have to wait too long
because Haley's ex auntie Kim Basinger
told Us Weekly that Haley sister Alya
and her cousin Kim's daughter Arlen are
in the wedding but up next for Justin is
a new single at DJ Khaled called
no-brainer and Khaled shared this promo
video j began hype for the track to drop
[Music]
we're doing it no brainer drops on
Friday and until then you guys can keep
a lot to eat tea online.com for these
stories and more I'll see you guys
tomorrow